[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone and welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
very excited to be talking about the
future of rap and nerd culture we have
LexA lexicon artist joining us on the
show today and who shout out to Ron for
finding you working with you in the past
and recommending to get you all yeah I
was trying to think how did we me do you
remember I was doing this thing at BFF
dot yeah we met on the internet and then
we met in person and then you invited me
on Fried Chicken and then this happens
yeah so yeah exactly so lexis been on
Fried Chicken - and now Alexa's on
simulation and those with that don't
know yet Lexus background
she is LexA lexicon artist Taiwanese
American rapper writer and creator and
she writes songs about nerd culture
personal identity and her experience as
an asian-american human being nice and
you can find all the links in the Bible
of the lexicon artist calm as well as
the Bandcamp Facebook Instagram patreon
YouTube and Twitter links so go follow
go explore her work alright let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world
oh well it's certainly gonna be an
uphill battle from here on out I think
people are getting smarter I think
overall people are getting more educated
people are getting healthier and overall
I think the quality of human beings is
probably increasing I think there
there's some studies that can attest to
that I would have to look them up but I
think I've read them in like a report or
something like that I don't have a
citation unfortunately but I think the
people the quality of the people is
increasing however the world they live
in is eventually going to get more and
more challenging especially in the next
50 200 years
a lot of these problems are gonna be
happening while I'm alive while we're
all alive as I move into like my 30s my
40s my 50s obviously climate change a
lot of shifts and political ideologies
and you know policies that are happening
in our country are gonna make our world
more difficult to survive in but I think
as human beings we will all survive and
thrive and find a way to live our lives
and enjoy our lives and be compassionate
human beings in the midst of all of this
turmoil going on because it's gonna get
a lot harder and hotter so sorry we're
bringing that realness in so fast but
you asked we have a lot of faith - and
Millennials and Gen Z in the future yeah
be a bright future for all we do we have
a lot of faith in that and I wanna learn
about the journey you know this this
music video and just you know you're
quirky you love nerd culture you are
producing great music right now you're
building up a really solid following
thank you how did this even happen for
you born in Evanston near Chicago yeah
and then you went to Taiwan for most of
your life yeah and then I'm curious how
it was like I want to you know become a
rapper you know seduced about this
journey sure I feel like it's a very
unconventional journey and most people
probably wouldn't expected of me of
someone who looked like me if they only
knew me from a superficial way which is
one of the reasons why I decided to work
on this project because you can't get to
know me
just by looking at me or just by making
assumptions about me there's so much
experience and so many stories that go
underneath this like kind of generic
look of an asian-american woman or
person that you can make a lot of
assumptions about but you can't really
see what's really going on and making a
rap projects kind of my way to express
what's really underneath the surface and
kind of expose who I really am as a
person to whoever's listening so yeah
it's a unusual journey and honestly you
know considering the culture that I was
brought up and most people probably
wouldn't have gone on this path because
I don't know how popular hip-hop even
was in Taipei when I was growing up
there like in the late 1990s throughout
the most of the 2000s until like 2012
that's where I was living I didn't find
a lot of people who are interested in
the same music that I was or interested
in the same movies or you know niche
Internet fandoms that I was so I spent a
lot of time on the Internet
in fact both of these pieces of clothing
are gifts from my mother this is a
Japanese bomber jacket and this is a
ironic t-shirt that says too much
Internet and she clearly understands
what I'm into which is great yeah my
parents are yeah very supportive they
never knew that I was going to do this
and I think they you know it can be
still kind of hard for them to
understand what I'm going for sometimes
because making music about nerd culture
is still kind of niche although I think
as we're going to discuss later it's
eventually going to be more kind of
conventional and mainstream and that's
the direction that I see the world going
in where being a nerd and being like
intelligent is considered mainstream I
love that yeah
I love that gonna be such a big key such
a big key yeah and I totally see that
happening but going back to what I was
saying earlier my my parents are were
supportive and have been supportive and
my parents put me on this music journey
by enrolling me in music lessons I'm
classically trained I play violin and
you know I played classical music for a
really long time until I started getting
into hip-hop music I listened to kind of
early two-thousands popular hip-hop
mostly like shady aftermath records like
Eminem 50 cent dr. Dre Snoop Dogg like
all those folks kind of were able to
reach an international audience and
that's how I was able to hear about them
and I listened to a lot of these people
just growing up when I was in you know
my preteen years 10 11 12 that's when oh
this kind of culture all the lyrics
started getting really embedded into my
head I really liked how subversive it
was and how transgressive it was
compared to the culture that I was
living in which is very collectivist and
very limited you're expected to do a
certain thing and to live a certain way
and to look a certain way and there's
not much of a kind of space to deviate
from the norm in a culture like Taiwan
or Korea or Japan for example and so I
really enjoyed accessing this American
culture because I felt like there was
more freedom to express who you really
were on the inside and that's how I got
into this culture throughout school I
knew I was wanted to be a rapper I wrote
my first rap song when I was 14 and it
was for an English class my English
teacher was very supportive and he gave
us all an assignment telling us to write
rap songs for our final project and then
yeah isn't that cool yeah he asked us to
record it and I recorded a song and I
submitted it and he pulled me aside
after I had submitted it and he said hey
Alex this is really good you should do
this more and I was like I never forget
that I'll never I never forgot that
so yeah that's that's how I got here I
mean I went to college I still have to
fulfill like you know the expectations
that were had of me in Asian families
are expected to go to and finish college
and so I did I studied something I was
interested in I studied psychology I
feel like I still have the opportunity
to study more psychology but I got a
bachelor's in psychology that's what I
have right now and when I graduated I
decided that maybe I should you know
give this rap career a shot so I started
writing my original songs and here we
are
Wow all right so when you're young you
know you're like 11 12 you're in Taipei
you're experiencing quite a bit of the
this collective vibe which in so many
ways this this is a different cultural
social fabric than the United States and
a lot of Europe let's say and just a
more collective versus more individual
essay and so when you are when you're
hearing the music of dr. Dre and Snoop
and mmm
getting all the way out to Taipei even
right and then that was inspiring you to
kind of find your own unleash your own
inner self yes that's so cool that that
that these things piece together with
like your it was an English teacher that
enabled the writing project the debt
that the rap writing project m14 yeah
yeah see this is the kind of cool stuff
it's a very common thing of people that
sit here is that when they speak it's
like oh my gosh the doors the influence
is that that yeah the kind of butterfly
effect you know if I hadn't had that
English teacher I may not have ever had
the guts to write something original I
had written like weird al' style
parodies and stuff and I was trying to
take existing material and adapt it to
you know adapted based on my own words
and my own thoughts but that isn't
really I think that isn't really like a
way to
be something other than weird al' you
don't weird out right yeah it's like
again listening to all those top 40
hip-hop artists when I was younger I
listened to their experiences and I
immediately understood that that was not
my experience and I couldn't appropriate
that experience and pretend that it was
mine but I could easily use the medium
and the cadence in the way that they
were writing these words and the
attitude behind it that kind of
braggadocious attitude of a hip-hop
artist and I could apply that to my own
experiences and I could use my own adapt
my own experiences and deliver it with
that same medium without kind of
pretending that I'm necessarily you know
part of this how do I say like
appropriating their culture does that
make sense you're pretending that I'm a
part of them when I'm really not yeah
you but the vibe I see yeah of the vibe
is critical in that year you have been
carrying that pipes filled through
they're just great it's great I'm
wondering you know with this how did you
then can you give this a little bit of
context here just so that we know what
are some of the cultural fabric vibes
that occur in some of the Asian
countries that push a little bit more
towards that collective mentality and
then and how do you feel about some of
the some of the benefits of that
versus some of the fact that it was
inhibiting your own identity as well mmm
one of the things that I can really say
without being too critical of it I'm cut
I'm I've always been very respectful to
my Asian roots and the culture that I
grew up in but lately I've been kind of
having more of a
like a reflective phase on the culture
that I grew up in and realizing that not
all of it is good you know there are
aspects of it that are really good
respect for parents is stronger I would
argue in Asian East Asian cultures and
you know to a certain extent being
collectivist is also really good for
social harmony but I think one of the
things that can be damaging is when
people feel the pressure to all act a
certain way and I'll look a certain way
then the opportunity for diversity
really shrinks and people who fall
outside of this limited scope of what it
means to be okay just get left out on
the wayside and that's how I felt when I
was younger I felt like I didn't fit in
that nobody was accepting me because I'm
gonna look like them I didn't act like
them and I didn't like the things that
they liked and in East Asia you're
expected let's go with the appearance
thing there is like a very strict
appearance let's take Korea for example
I just came back from Korea I'm not
Korean but I visited Korea and I kind of
got to experience their culture a little
bit there's this very strict look for
what a Korean woman should look like and
it that's the look that appears in media
in kpop in Korean dramas there's a very
specific look for a beautiful woman in
Korea and it goes all the way down to
having a certain facial structure to
having certain features to having a
certain hair style and hair color and
what I realize is that if you don't fall
within that scope then you're not
considered attractive and that
especially for cultures where
appearances are really important for the
prospects of women and getting married
and the pressure for women to get
married is a lot heavier than it is here
in a lot of ways that can be really
damaging and people who don't look like
that feel the pressure to look like that
and they feel the pressure to maybe
surgically alter their features so that
they can look closer to that ideal and I
don't think that that's healthy and
while I think it's okay for people to
decide what they want to do with their
bodies it's important to have bodily
autonomy I also think that a lot of
people feel like they don't have a
choice in looking a certain way or and
wanting to look a certain way and in
America on the other hand there's
different kinds of niches where
different kinds of body shapes body
sizes hair styles hair colors facial
features skin colors are accepted and
considered attractive by at least a good
amount of the population it's like the
decorating the avatar
right yeah exactly so having more of
this diversity and having people who
accept people who look different a wider
range of it's okay to look like this
makes it so that people don't feel so
bad about the way they look right and
people feel more accepting people can
always turn on the TV and find someone
who looks like them and say hey it's
okay to look like that I guess I'm an
okay human being right and so that's one
of the major reasons I think
collectivism can be bad it limits
diversity and it limits the amount of
people who who can be role models for
other people in the world you know and
then give us the good on the social
harmony side of things to look good on
the social harmony I think especially
when it comes to family dynamics
there is a level of respect and a level
of gratitude coming from children to
their parents to their extended family
to their grandparents to their aunts to
their uncles big extended families can
be somewhat common in Asia although it's
getting less common because of declining
child birth rates but traditionally
Asian cultures have had big families so
I look together and this value of family
and the recognition that regardless of
the flaws of one's family a lot of times
they are like looking out for you and
trying to do the best for you even if
you know it can be misguided sometimes I
think I think it's really valuable and
shaped me a lot as a kid and shapes me a
lot as an adult I will always feel
grateful to my family regardless of
whether sometimes I agree with them or
not and I think that really promotes a
very healthy you know collective healthy
community that a person can exist in you
know even if they don't have that many
friends or have a relationship they can
always depend on their family mm-hmm
yeah this nuance I've been also trying
to help explain to some of the people
that have only been in the West and that
and and it's really hard to to it's good
that you gave both of these perspectives
you grew up you've now spent a good
amount of time in both of these
environments to have this deeper nuance
I do think there's a lot of good code
that comes from East over time yeah and
even in all the way up to today with the
way that China is just roaring as a
global power that I think the West needs
to had take a hefty dose of humility yes
and yeah yeah yeah so and also build a
very strong bridge between East Asia and
the United States because I think that
can ensure
like a good chance for world peace
across the planet yeah especially when
the major world powers are China in the
United States I think it's really
important for both of these countries
and the people in them to understand
what makes the other person tick and a
question for you how familiar are you
with East Asia in general like have you
spent a lot of time there because from
my experience Americans you know
Americans regardless maybe white
Americans black Americans Latino
Americans but also Asian Americans who
haven't spent time in the East don't
really understand what the culture is
like I guess and they don't understand
the good things that come from the
culture and they don't understand the
bad things that come from the culture
and they may what ends up manifesting
from there maybe obsession what the
culture is oh this culture is all good
or if they have like the opposite
reaction then let's say like an Asian
American who feels like they don't want
to be seen as Asian they just want to be
seen as American but they never spend
any time in Asia maybe they'll have like
the opposite reaction of like oh like
Asian cultures like all bad but if you
haven't spent any time there it's really
really hard to like understand
especially if you don't have relatives
or friends who are from there and so I'm
curious to hear about your experience
just on a real quick note the the yes I
think there for the last several
thousand years that have there have been
very ancient practices that have come
out of hate Asian cultures that I've
been able to practice deep meditations
and philosophies that I think have
drastically changed my life for the
better
and I think every but everyone in the
West can at least take a taste into some
of that and potentially I'm chill on
some of the egoic vibes that happen here
yeah I'm a lot of the time and at the
same time I do recognize what you said
earlier about even something as simple
as decorating the avatar the West is
like decorate your avatar how you want
yeah and like that's really cool and can
be empowering and so I this is this is
stuff I haven't been yet and Ron have
you been it easy yet no um so I'm not
saying that you're not an expert I'm
sure that you studied it a lot and read
a lot of books I'm not trying to call
you out toto crazy things happening like
the belt road initiative there's so many
interesting things that are occurring in
that part of the world and even in the
last thousands of years but but but just
on on a on a global cohesion level Ron
and I have had several conversations now
with people that we've interviewed that
I've asked us when are you going to come
out to you know Wuhan University or out
near Shanghai you know these are like
these are actually like bit like bid the
people are now starting to gain more
interest in in having us go out there
and we want to spend Iran we're not sure
quite unruhe
I don't want speak for him but I want to
spend several months out there
interviewing hundreds of scientists and
entrepreneurs and artists and people at
the edge of their fields and I want our
channel to have hundreds of people from
from Asia and to be able to then
showcase how similar in many ways our
humanity is our desire for peace love
dignity prosperity
I'm just these similar um fabrics that I
think and can bring that world peace
thing together so really yeah that's a
that's a bit on on where hopefully and
we can see and with your help people
like us can do things like grow okay so
let's go into how did you get when you
were when you're when you're you know
studying in high school and whatnot
and then you're like how did the how did
the bit to go out to Berkeley to do
psychology come up as I mentioned
earlier going to college is kind of a
requirement in these Asian families
especially with my family my family is a
family full of academics my both of my
parents are Wednesday like higher
education and you know my dad went to
higher higher education
and so you know all my family is well
educated either in law or medicine or we
I don't think we really have any
engineers in the house but yeah like my
family's super educated were all
academics and we were expected to be
academics and my older brother ended up
going to law school so he ended up
following in the path of the academics
where did he go
Duke law he just got oh he went to the
u.s. to do yeah yeah interesting so then
you were also finding your way out okay
yeah we both went to college in the u.s.
he went to the East Coast I went to
Berkeley and you know he just graduated
from law school I've been doing this but
you know in the you might think that
these maybe ranked like differently on
like the value system you're on whether
like one is better than the other but I
would say that we've both succeeded in
our own ways me and my brother I love my
brother a lot he has always been my rock
we're super close anyway that song was
good do you sing in any other tracks are
just that one well working on a new
album and there's a lot more singing in
the new album great yeah and hasn't been
released yet but yeah there's a lot more
melody there's a lot more singing
courses and hooks in the new album and
it's more catchy and I'm excited to
unveil it it's just still in process
yeah but about like going to school I
was always expected to go to college I
applied to colleges UC Berkeley was
probably the best school that I got into
and I was very happy to be accepted and
going there was you know kind of just a
given
I was always expected to go to school in
the US and get a degree and then do
something with that degree or not I
don't know if I'm specifically using my
degree to do rap music now but some
overlap there's
I like writing very psychologically
driven analytical song yeah that kind of
engaged my knowledge about the brain and
emotions and things like that stuff that
I learned in school so a lot of my
education actually comes through in my
writing but yeah and that's a big part
of the future of rap is embedding some
deeper potentially scientific
potentially meaning there's yeah yeah
rather than some of the existing what we
could call the money women materialistic
possessions there's a lot of that and I
think a lot of that appears in
mainstream rap nowadays especially in
kind of the mumble rap generation where
it's just kind of people going like
about you know money drugs whatever
there's a lot of current rap though and
also you know older rap that is
underground as always talked about
things like politics or you know raging
Against the Machine or we're not talking
about toasters we're talking about the
Machine yeah and like social justice and
you know also raps about varieties of
different pop culture icons like movies
or like horror or you know books I think
that has always existed has just always
been underground so my expectation for
the future of rap is that that kind of
stuff gets more popular and I'm already
seeing it with let's say rappers such as
logic who are really kind of getting
into the spotlight nowadays he got a
feature in Rick and Morty right he did
like a cameo on that show and his rap is
very convoluted often very analytical
often very intellectual like poetic I
guess and yeah so what rappers like
logic for example not saying that he is
the only one but there is a there are a
lot of people that are coming out of the
woodwork who are starting to
you know bring their education or bring
kind of more abstract like convoluted
stuff esoteric elements into their
writing and I'm starting to see it more
and more in the mainstream which is
great so I really want that kind of like
nice underground stuff that has always
been around to go mainstream yeah yeah
and the the generation that were a part
of and even younger than us I think is
gonna be a big part of pushing that up
having music that has meaning embedded
in it
spiritual music like when was the last
time a rapper rapped about CRISPR or
neural prosthetics or block chaining
cryptocurrency right well I know a
couple of rappers I could list off like
three that rap about blockchain and
cryptocurrency immediately there you go
that's what I'm saying you're deep in
the scene so when is it gonna become
mainstream and so okay so then when you
picked the mind and you pin you're now
seeing yourself also acting a little bit
more in the direction of of embedding
some of the things that you learned into
the music that you that you produce I
want to know the words actually Lex the
lexicon artists those words yeah you
know you had teach us about because Alex
Sun blue yes yeah so yeah so how did
this happen so Alex only is my full name
obviously alex is my first name it's not
sure for anything it's just Alex which i
think is great because I'm like somewhat
non-binary as well and so it doesn't
kind of immediately give like a feminine
vibe to it it's very like uni sex which
i think is really good analog for my
personality and my identity in general
so alex is my name but and son leo
those are my two nan given names I guess
son is my mom's last name Lee was my
dad's last name but Alex had decided to
give myself a nickname when I started
doing this
shortened it to Lex because it was even
more kind of like gender-neutral which
is what I preferred and so Lex the
lexicon artist is the lexicon artist is
a portmanteau of lexicon and con artists
so Connor this is someone who like kind
of tricks people right lexicon means
vocabulary or the words in your brain so
lexicon artist means word trickster and
that was what I started off with when I
first started writing my goal was to
write really complicated SAT approved
like big vocabulary like rap lyrics and
rap really fast
that was the goal I was like yeah I'm
gonna play with words I'm gonna be like
a word trickster that was the goal but
as I continued to work on this project
it started to have more meaning to it
and I eventually started to value
substance over style and so I've slowed
down my rapping a little bit I
incorporate more themes of you know
emotional analysis psychology pop
culture stuff that people can relate to
my own experiences as opposed to kind of
just being like that I can rep really
fast yeah so like the kind of concept of
the project has evolved over time but I
would still say that lexicon artist is a
good way to describe it because it's the
usage of words that really matters to me
as a writer yeah yeah and it's is so
evident in the music because in 2016
when he first started piecing this
together for me I listened to raging ego
and that was released two years later
June 2018 yeah and that had 11 tracks on
it and I remember listening to it and
ice and I told Ron I told him that I was
so happy to finally hear because I had a
little taste of like hip-hop and rap
that had some more meaning yeah but you
gave me that big smile on like oh thank
you well cuz I was like this is what's
up this is such a big part of our future
I'm so happy to be seeing it rising
thank you and so
hopefully hopefully let's let's let's
hear some of that from you how in that
first couple years and from 2006 2018
did you figure out how to get your
footing in the space and get launched
off because there's likely also other
people that may be in the same shoes or
want to know how it happened sure I'm
always happy to help people who like are
interested have the talent and want to
get on their feet and you know start
working on projects so I can definitely
talk about how I did it it was weird
because like when I started I had
basically really never written an
original song and really one day I was
just sitting in my living room living
room with my friend and I was like hey I
think I'm gonna start writing rap songs
and he was like yeah do it
and I wrote a rap song I brought it to
an open mic the started plow in Berkeley
it's a Tuesday night open mic and one of
my friends who is a comedian invited me
to go to that open mic to check it out
and like to perform my stuff I was like
okay cool let me give this a shot and I
performed my stuff and it ended up
having a really good response and that
was the first time I ever performed like
Lex lyrics and that was a great way for
me to start believing that I could
actually do it so jumping off from there
I started writing more stuff I started
writing songs I started performing more
at the open mics
I checked out different open mic so I
got my start in the open mic scene
around here I would do open mics in
Oakland San Francisco and Berkeley for
the most part and once I was started to
get known enough in the open mic scene I
started to get show invites so I started
playing more kind of like official shows
where I had a longer set I got a lot of
help from folks who are in the local
scene to kind of start getting me on my
feet to get more shows they taught me
how to promote local shows and still I
started setting up shows
and that eventually helped me find my
band I found you know instrumentalists
who were willing to work with me and
play with me live and pretty much just
just started gigging and eventually I
also you know as I continued writing I
sourced my ideas from the experiences
that I was having along the way I would
write about how it felt to write a song
or how it felt to perform or how it felt
to watch someone who I admired perform
and I would write about my relationship
life I would write about my education
and pretty much just anything that I
thought would make a good song would be
compelling or relatable to someone I
would write a song about and that
happened throughout the whole two years
that I first worked on it and I released
all of the songs that I was working on
in raging ego for in 2018 so all of that
that you hear the eleven songs it was
like throughout two years in the making
yeah and I basically played gigs a lot
and I started networking on the internet
- and I found people who did similar
things to me on the Internet and I
established a connection with that
community things started blowing up
around 2018 but I can pause here first
so that so we can unpack yeah I want to
unpack what were you wanting to pause
for oh I was wanting to pause because I
felt like I was talking a lot I thought
you were like as I'm about to drop
something quick so now what what we can
unpack yes yes so in like 2016 2017 I
think this is also very similar with
artists with comedians with musicians
with rappers that that there's always
this period of like open mic or like you
know you got you like the first time
it's like I'm gonna write okay great and
then it's like I'm gonna perform it's
like great yeah so go and get it go do
it yeah and then you do it and then you
get feedback from the audience about
what's working what's not working you go
and refine you keep going
got to go to Oakland SF Berkeley and
hustle and like do multiple gigs and
like keep going and so okay so then that
content-based built up but then how did
you end up identifying like who could
help you produce the music that you
could then rap over for the album that's
a great question and really I would say
that part and producing the music and
creating videos and kind of elevating my
game to the next step beyond just kind
of doing one song and an open mic and
hustling kind of like groundwork is what
I like to call it groundwork the first
two years were probably just groundwork
you know like 2016 2017 I was doing a
lot of like local shows I was networking
with the people around me I was getting
advice getting feedback from the people
who are also in the local scene who are
like close to me and I was able to
improve a lot based on that but it
didn't really get me beyond being in
this area see the reason that I was able
to start creating music first of all and
also have my name be beyond the Bay Area
was because of the internet and I got to
meet a community called nerdcore hip hop
on the Internet
nerdcore hip hop and that's the that's
the kind of industry or genre that I
work in a lot of the time there's an
industry slasher genre for this now yes
nerdcore hip hop and it's awesome is so
great yes or where did the queer does
the community live like subreddits or
where did they live ah there's a nerd
core subreddit for sure
the online community initially existed
on a
forum called rhyme torrents it's not
active anymore but that most of the
rhyme torrents people have moved into a
Facebook group called in Arcore hip hop
I'm about to join it's there's a lot of
trolls just just warning you there's
always a lot of trouble
I got trolled when I first joined so I
first joined the group and they trolled
the hell out of me but then they started
realizing that I was pretty good you're
serious yeah that I was serious about
you know getting into the industry
writing music performing music and
touring I was serious about all of that
and they started noticing and they also
started noticing that I became better
because I didn't start off being so good
you know we always improve as artists I
started off for being an OK rapper to
being an actually pretty good rapper and
as they noticed I started making more
connections with folks who are already
actively touring with inner core hip hop
there is an official South by Southwest
nerdcore showcase sweet yeah there is a
music and gaming festival in Maryland
that's also very well attended
it's called Mac fest music and gaming
and that's kind of intersection of
gaming related rap and video game music
chip tunes things like that
and so I was able to perform at both of
these events basically this year 2019 so
because of the connections that I made
through nerdcore hip hop so yeah a lot
of it had to do with going up there like
to the festivals meeting people in
person but honestly these people exist
all over the map there's people in Texas
there's a huge Texas family that exists
there's people in New York people in LA
people in Denver Colorado it's like
really all over the map and in order to
obviously network with them you have to
know them on the internet first but you
also have to meet them at events and so
that's what I did and would nerdcore hip
hop be one of the reasons that you found
producers to help you with those ok yes
that's exactly what happened so all the
producers that I work with with the
exception of one or two have been people
that I found through this site they're
rappers on
well they're rappers in this group there
are producers in this group more so
there are people who are great people
and who are very talented and have the
skillset to produce music so I'm a
composer right
I write music I can compose violin parts
piano parts I don't play guitar but I
can compose like kind of guitar parts
and I guess I can compose bass parts you
know stuff that's like fairly like
writing driven if that makes sense but I
can't produce very well that skill set
comes from someone who has worked for
years and years with like audio
productions systems like digital audio
workstations someone like run for
example yeah like you have to be very
familiar with technical side of it and I
don't have that skill set so I was
actually able to find people who were
able to take the compositions that I
made that we're basically like skeletons
or you know demos like a songwriters
demo and kind of make it better and play
instruments and produce beats prettiest
you know drums effects and create like a
complete piece of music to rap over so I
have a little bit of a hand in the
composition of the songs yes but to
produce the songs I had to find people
who had the skill set to do that and
that group was a really big reason yeah
see your resourcefulness that's a major
key of people achieving what their
ultimate destinies are is how
resourceful can you be along the way to
find nerdcore hip-hop how colorsource
ville can you be because to be able to
find that community go to the
communities events connect with the
producers there ask them to help you
produce the music that you're working on
you know and be fearless about about how
we're gonna end up falling on our face
along the way and it's not going to be
as good only first start so love hearing
these stories and then you work with
multiple producers to make the first oh
yeah there's so many producers on there
and that's kind of how I prefer working
anyway because
I like having a variety of different
styles I try not to limit myself to one
genre I've done like a surf Punk track
with Michael kill I did like kind of a
chip tune excuse me trip teen Punk track
with clap and pop and they're just a
variety of different styles and sounds
on the album and I always want to engage
those different influences that I have
from rock to middle to chill jazz you
know there's so many different types of
music that I could rap over and I don't
want to limit myself to just one sound
so I like working with a variety of
different people yeah but all of that
kind of all of the all the ideas all the
executive production like how the
album's gonna shape out what the themes
are gonna be that's all me and yeah your
your songs are also tons of you said
tons of different producers that are
giving you different beats which is
awesome and then also you have the names
of the songs and what you talk about
them like a sales freak the l-word curse
of curiosity psych major you really like
those titles it's not like my new
Ferrari I write a song called my new
Ferrari just because it's gonna be so
fake who did the animation on mob
explosion is that the name of the song
yeah it's a it's from the anime oh okay
yeah it's from the show yeah so whoever
directed that show and made the
animation did that so we took the
animation of it from the show and I cut
it up to kind of you know to the music
cool yes and alright so then like you
know so walk us through writing songs
like this and and how you kind of
identify what the purpose of these of
this of these songs on this album are
and like yeah how you piece it all
together
ha it's an art not a science mmm that's
what I have to say about that it's um
you can't control creativity it's one of
the many curses of creativity some of it
is a science music is quite scientific
like you know music theories very
mathematical and very scientific but
figuring out what to write what stories
are gonna resonate with people and what
you're inspired to write at that
particular moment and what sounds
natural and what is actually going to
reach your audience that's all art
there's no one way to do it you can
start with a beat and then write lyrics
over it you can start with the lyrics
and then have someone create a beat
around it you can do kind of both at the
same time go back and forth have some
lyrics go make a beat and then kind of
mash the beat to the lyrics and then
write more lyrics so there is no one
process in which a song gets made it all
depends on what's happening here and you
really can't control it and I really
wish that there was a way to control it
and to harness that energy so I could
take it out whenever I wanted but I
can't really do that
I can sit some time down for me to write
but I can't guarantee that what I write
is gonna be good so for example cursive
creativity is a song that I wrote for
weight not for I wrote in three to four
hours while I was sitting at my night
job at my desk there was a period of
downtime I was like I got this idea
three or four hours that was it
songs done mm-hmm what are the songs on
there
man I think sales freak took me a really
long time like that was just shoving
everything I knew about psychology and
sales into a song and I was like oh
that's gonna be funny to write a song
about sales in psychology like nobody
writes a song about that yeah yeah even
said that that is a profound thing
Thanks it's just so lacking like sales
in psychology are such a beautiful mix
and like why have there's there has
there been so little music film art
about those two things put together and
I like how you were just like like you
just came up with yeah it was like I
used to do sales you know I I was a tech
sales person and so I have a lot of
experience in sales I have a lot of
experience in psychology so let's write
a song about it make it funny so that
was how I wrote that song but it took a
really long time because I was taking
all these terminologies and like putting
it into the song and it was kind of a
more calculated song as opposed to a
rush of creativity it was more like
let's make this perfect and so that
ended up taking a lot longer and yeah so
those two songs were written via
different processes and I can never
guarantee what process is going to be
the driving force of a song as I said
it's an art not a science and I wish it
could be more scientific but a lot of
times you just gotta let the creativity
take you over and write what comes to
your heart and then test it with an
audience to see if it works and if it
doesn't work maybe scrap that song and
write another one so you have to be okay
with failure too because sometimes I've
written songs that I've never published
because I thought it was a good idea at
the time and then people are like oh
this is actually kind of problematic and
I was like okay then I won't do it give
us an example I mean what was the
problem
I have written like party songs like I
have written like straight-up party
songs like yeah let's get drunk let's
party it was like one of the first songs
that I've ever written and I was just
like yeah it's like fun you know people
enjoyed doing that and then people are
like is this actually making a good
message on alcoholism and alcohol
addiction I was like you know what I
don't think it is so I'm gonna scrap it
excellent everybody knowing everybody
that knows me knows that I would have
appreciated it elects like kind of
analyzing drug addiction and alcohol
addiction and substance dependency it
can be really really insightful you just
got to do in the right way and in that
song I wasn't doing it in the right way
I was kind of glorifying it yeah I know
yeah and I know I have a lot of friends
who have talked about their own
substance dependence in their music and
that's really powerful but personally I
haven't had any substance dependence
issues yeah so I wouldn't write I want
to write a song about something that
isn't authentic to me I can't write a
song about my new Ferrari because I
don't own one you know I don't have the
money to own one I make a parody about
it I can make up I could I hear about a
parody of Old Town Road called my own
new Ferrari but yeah that's another
thing it has to be authentic all these
songs are mostly autobiographical yes
they're all related to my experience in
some way they're all about something
that's authentic to me I would never
pretend to write about something that I
know nothing about except the l word
love uh yeah I was experienced
experienced that which is whatever about
it but yeah it's um that one's a weird
one I told you earlier that like a lot
of weirdness
it's so weird I love the weirdness
people think it's such a good song like
I have so many fans who are like I love
that song and I'm like that's like I
think it's so cheesy but I felt like I
had to write it I don't even perform it
anymore
but like maybe I should bring it back
the more weird and is like the more self
expressive and so I think we're totally
we're moving to a culture where the more
weird it is that the more real it is the
more authentic it is and this is the
type of stuff that we really want that's
such a badass picture be performing yeah
so so um also another thing that you
mention I thought was so cool is that
the this is nerd culture I mean what you
write is nerd culture like whether it's
you finishing a song three to four hours
or you having a piece together tons of
research into a song right that we're
having to scrap a song because people
say like look at yourself in the mirror
look at your what you want to propagate
out into the world that's really good
powerful stuff that you're able to make
the decision and say no that you didn't
want to to surround yourself with good
people they helped you with that very
important super critical community is
super important having people who prop
you up and tell you when you're messing
up and not just shovel you with praise
all the time tell you when you're doing
wrong that's rude and correct you and
you having the mental fortitude and
flexibility to actually listen to the
people around you super critical if you
can't change if you can't get better
you'll never succeed
yet and taking the feedback no matter
how it comes if it comes with a with a
in in wit at first if they give you a
layer of icing or or if they just give
you right into the Red Hot Chili Peppers
or I prefer to I prefer it coming right
hot right I'm a no-frills kind of person
I'm just like direct direct AF and then
but then we have to tailor it to people
how their psychological needs are when
we want to deliver feedback so it's a
very dynamic there now the question I
just wanted to embed quick in that
segment was just that like the songs are
totally nerd culture they're like
epically nerd culture Thanks and like
what is happening as you are like
performing you've released this album
you've been performing now and even the
I mean this is even before talking about
the the newest album special which came
out five tracks January of this year
yeah and then you mentioned the the mag
that you went and performed on so
they're pleased you went to perform that
it's just and you're performing around
the bay with your band yeah but just
like what has been the feedback that
you've been getting from the from people
online that are telling you about nerd
culture and your songs as well as the
audience's live yeah teach us about that
I get a couple of different reactions I
can tell you about the ones that come
out the most often I think number one is
people find my stuff relatable and they
love hearing about experiences that they
can see themselves in and feelings and
emotions that they have lived themselves
and so they're able to listen to my
music maybe in the car on the way to
work on the go at the gym pump
themselves up lift themselves up
emotionally and have a strong emotional
effect on their own lives because they
can understand what I'm saying
and they can understand the things that
I've gone I've been going through
because they have had a similar
experience as outcasts in the world and
that's a big population a big audience
of people who listen to nerdcore music
is people who never felt like they
belonged anywhere people who felt like
they were ostracized in school for
liking things that weren't popular or
for liking things that other people
didn't like and going back to my early
days I felt like that because the people
around me were into the things that I
was into and so all these experiences
kind of surfaced in this album in the
other albums and songs that I've made
and people were able to find themselves
and see themselves in it and that I say
is representation representation it's
extremely important because if someone
can hear themselves in a song or see
themselves on TV then they can see that
and be like that's like me I guess I'm
okay and everyone just wants to feel
okay you know everyone wants to feel
okay and see that they're there life is
not so bad to find comfort that other
other people are living the lives that
they're living and that's the kind of
comfort and compassionate understanding
that I aim to deliver it to people by
creating these songs so relatability is
number one let me refine just quick bit
on that on relatability also if you
propagate nerd culture through the music
that you're doing as well so not only is
it that people can then hear it
themselves and say that Wow
like that emotionally resonates with me
finally I'm hearing that in music that I
listen to but also they get to
potentially see that nerd culture is
cool yeah yeah and that's a huge thing
too that's how you're taught at the
beginning you're like we have so many
things that we're needed there are
challenges that we need to solve and
nerd culture is going to come in and
kick those challenges asses yeah and so
that's huge is that that inspire the
inspiring force that goes through people
as well that they can you know see you
talking about a big challenge in the
world and then rise up and and tackle
that and you know the see it be it thing
is so critical and
that's another part of the relatability
a thing to see someone who looks like
them or lives like them be successful
and they might see me and have the
reaction of I can do that too she's
successful and she is being open and
she's rapping about her life maybe I can
do that
maybe I can pursue the things that I
like I want to provide that
encouragement for people too yes yeah
yes yes and you shattered through some
of the cultural taboos that you have as
well to move up into the position that
you're in so that's another critical one
is that shattering the taboos along the
way yeah shattering the stereotypes the
taboos there's a stereotype of Asian
women being boring or submissive or you
know not outspoken or you know not cool
there's a variety of different
stereotypes that surrounds someone who
looks like me to the point that when I
went on tour a lot of people when I
showed up at the venue didn't think that
I was the performer they asked me if I
was the sound person and I would have to
look them in the eye and say I am the
performer and that really changes
people's mind I think it's really
important to do stuff that alters
someones perceptions a little bit and
maybe changes their minds of something
that they previously had a preconception
of in the past and if you can change
their preconceptions then you can expand
their mind and allow them to learn new
things and you've taught them one new
thing just by showing up you know and so
shattering cultural stereotypes taboos
of me being part of the culture you know
being open up about you know mental
illness things like that is also really
important for folks who are dealing with
the same issues who see someone who
looks like me talking about these things
they can feel like they have someone to
look up to and I want to be that person
so yeah that is another thing by the way
is Asian women Asian folks in general
have usually had a really positive
response to seeing me
mostly because I am a source of
representation for them within hip-hop
with a nerd culture and within music in
general I think there could be even more
Asian American musicians coming out and
you know being successful I think it's
already starting to happen but I think
it could be even more and now that crazy
rich Asians is out a lot of movie
studios are really jumping on Asian
focus stories and pilots and media
content it's getting really popular
because people are starting to see that
these stories are profitable and people
are actually interested in seeing the
experiences of these people and I think
that's the same way with music too and
so that's the other feedback that I've
gotten can I share the less yes it of
course relatability yogya the last bit
of feedback that is very common is girl
power ooh yeah good yeah most nerdcore
hip-hop artists are men they can be
white men mostly white men there's
plenty of black men too but they're
mostly men and women in the space
there's a couple who are active but
they're very rare and folks who are
regularly touring and experiencing kind
of a upward growth are and active
nowadays are you know even rarer and
I have a lot of women at my shows you
know and a lot of times these woman's
are these women are there to see the
male performance that they cannot to see
because for example I went on tour last
year for two months across the country
with a performer named MC Chris and he
used to be on Adult Swim and he's also a
rapper in the nerdcore space and there
are a lot of women fans and male fans
and non-binary fans who came out to see
MC Chris cuz he has a huge following in
the world and in the US but I got the
reaction from a lot of women when I went
on stage saying that they didn't expect
to see a woman opening for MC Chris and
that they were so excited to see a woman
you know be on that stage and rap about
nerd culture because they are involved
in nerd culture and some of them even
want to write rap songs yes
but they never thought that they could
do it or they never saw someone who was
doing it to encourage them to do it and
now that they saw me they suddenly
realize that they can do it too and
they're also so happy to see someone who
is making it out there in the world as a
woman and as a nerd so I get a lot of
like nerd nerd girl power responses
they're so happy to see like a female MC
in a genre hip-hop that is generally
already male-dominated but you add the
nerd aspect to it and it's even more
male-dominated because a lot of you know
nerd culture often discourages women
from participating whether in gaming or
being involved in stem you know there's
a lot of like cultural artifacts that
make it really hard for women to
participate a lot of the time and so
that's the feedback that I get from
women they're like girl rapper I like ya
and that's another one of the CEO be it
things is so critical if they're if they
can see you then they can go home and
say that finally okay great I'm gonna
get writing because I've had all those
ideas and I want to go and make them
happen so that's huge it's huge and
there's another whole a dynamic of it
along the lines of like what what what
what females can bring to to the table
of values and principles that are
sometimes lacking for for what men are
trying to build or work on so see you
like that yes I write a song called see
a bit I love it yeah I love it that's
huge that's huge and um you know another
interesting thing is that what is their
name Joe Joe Joe Joe see what has a song
about that oh yeah the young girl down
in LA and yeah if you can see it you can
be it yeah and like so her yeah her
that's another interesting thing is that
hip-hop and rap seems to be moving in
the direction of also inspiring and
engaging at deeper levels than just yeah
materialism and all the other gunk
occasional materialism can be a lot of
fun but it shouldn't be all of it live
their lives but but the uprising of nerd
culture is is coming okay other other
thoughts that I think is important to
explain okay you have your band guitar a
bassist violinist and a drummer mm-hmm
you guys do live shows in the Bay and
then so for those that are local you can
find that info on the website right
lexicon artist calm yeah I don't think
updated my most recent show but I mean
the upcoming show but I'm gonna be
playing a phantom Akon this weekend so
yeah that's the 25th
yeah the 25th yeah yeah that's Phantom
icon is is in San Jose it's an anime
convention and
the event is music fest for Famine
Phantom icon and it's the official music
festival for the convention and it's
happening in the music venue that's
across the street from the Convention
Center called San Jose Civic yeah that's
pretty much it
we're playing along with a couple of
other great bands and also some bands
from Japan so yeah there's like
international headliners and also local
opening action we're one of the opening
act so he's pretty awesome
I mean San Jose Civic is I think seats a
thousand plus it's a big venue yeah
it's a big venue like yeah that's a
looking forward to it 25th also you have
another NYC performance on June 8th yeah
June 8th that's gonna be a solo
performance working with a couple of
minor core hip hop colleagues dual core
Michael Kill and shaver the Dark Lord
and we're burglar so all of these folks
are like in the nerdcore hip-hop scene
so to speak they work in different kind
of feels like Packer rap there there's
some as I mentioned earlier there's some
rappers that rap about like you know
blockchain and you know hacking and
pentesting and stuff like that and
there's also like pop culture rap and
you know wordplay and all that sort of
thing so that's gonna be a more like a
specific nerdcore performance and that's
happening on June 8th and that's part of
like a security conference that's going
on over there that is actually more of a
secret so I don't know if I could share
it out here and it's like an invite-only
security conference yeah
yeah but it's happening in New York City
June 8th ok and then ok this parts also
this is this is this is something that
every almost every I think artists
entrepreneur creator just every person I
think goes through this this existential
crisis that happens in life and you
publish some content about some of the
ways that you were feeling about this
is one way to put it it was like a blog
post right yeah I like doing that I just
felt a need to kind of tell my audience
why I was silent for a little bit
I was busy spending time with family but
yes go ahead well it's just that there's
this this tendency with the we we we
have all this it's like a hyper reality
is what we've created in many ways with
the social media where everything is on
the best possible way of displaying
oneself and so we're less likely to talk
about how we feel depressed or how we
feel like a lack of love or that what
are my needs you know I'm really not
like talking about that as much as we
are trying to say that I travelled
somewhere really beautiful or that my
like this it's [ __ ] awesome so
there's kind of like a shift that I
think that is happening a little bit
like an occasional funny selfie like
that yeah we take and stuff like these
are really I think important things to
highlight so when you when you made that
post I also realized how you know we
also have went through a lot of ups and
downs with building this and basically
every creator goes through their ups and
downs through the past even through yeah
exactly and so um tell us a bit about
your trajectory with that with the last
name a couple years in the ups and downs
that you've been feeling yeah yeah
really the ups and downs have been 2018
and 2019 the last two years experienced
a huge amount of growth last year it was
my first time at South by Southwest and
I also went on tour and I released
raging ego which was my first like major
release right and so I was experiencing
a lot of momentum and a lot of speed in
my career and I grew really fast
especially when I went on tour it was a
really great opportunity for me I made a
lot of fans on the road it was very very
successful this year has also been
equally as much work but the success is
showing itself in ways that are maybe
not as immediate and maybe not as
obvious and so I've had to
grappled with that and understand that
just because I'm not experiencing
success and at as fast a pace as I was
experiencing it last year doesn't mean
that I'm a failure
and it's been difficult because I have
done - I think well man it's gonna be
three now but it's like - like major
festival gigs and then like you know
some gigs in the middle I've been
working on stuff I released a project
earlier this year but really I'm trying
to match the success of last year and
it's always a constant feeling of
pressure like Oh am I gonna am I gonna
move as fast as I did last year and I'm
gonna my gonna be as badass as I was
last year and if I don't does that mean
my career is over
and I think maybe that's why creatives
experienced that we're constantly
worried about what we're doing and
whether it's going to succeed and
whether any of it is even meaningful at
all and whether any of it is changing
anyone's mind and that's an experience
that I went through when I took a little
bit of a break
earlier this month throughout an entire
month I visited some family in Korea I
spent some time in North Carolina for
when my brother graduated and it was
really a time for me to reflect on the
course of this project so far whether it
has been meaningful to me and has
brought me joy
whether it's brought other people joy
and essentially whether I should
continue doing it and I think I'm not
gonna quit anytime soon but it can be
discouraging sometimes because you
wonder if it's really making any
difference in a world that is impacted
by such negative forces all the time by
political policies by climate change
by a lot of suffering that's going on in
this world that I'm not sure writing
silly songs is really going to change
and I always want to do stuff that has
an impact on people and ultimately I
really want to change the world right
now I'm just assessing whether this
project that I'm doing isn't cheating
that goal or whether it's just something
that I'm using to feed my own
meaningless simulated existence and you
know sometimes I think maybe it really
is a little bit of both
we have to live in the moment and do the
things that we enjoy we have to bring
immediate joy to others that's exactly
what music is for it's for people to
listen to and for people to enjoy and
for people to experience like immediate
pleasure in the moment but whether it
has any like long-term effect on like
the way our world works is like
something that's a little bit more
disputable especially when I write like
you know kind of just off the cuff like
silly songs that don't really have
anything to do with you know like social
justice or whatever and you know I think
that's where like the existentialist
question comes and is what I'm doing
important I think what you're doing is
important do you think it's important
yes and I think that you are being very
hard on yourself because because what
you are doing is extremely important and
sometimes here's one of the things that
people don't see is that it's hard it's
hard because of hedonic adaptation that
were constantly adapting to the to the
freshest level of where we're at that we
it's really hard for us to objectively
look back and say holy [ __ ] I am so
grateful I can't believe that I made it
through that last year look at how many
fans came out to my shows look at how
many of them tell me about the girl
power look at how many of them you know
what I mean yeah so so to really
objectively reflect back and be like wow
my work is impactful and furthermore
I don't even know what it is really
happening the butterfly effect when
people comment on the videos and say
certain things about how we change to
some of their perceptions they're
changing their life that we don't
actually know what they're going and
telling their family their community
what projects they're building what
challenges they're solving the butterfly
effect is so hard to calculate about
what work you're how many people you're
impacting and what they're actually
doing yeah with what you've taught them
yeah and your music isn't just silly
it's also meaningful nerd culture is a
ton of meaning embedded into it so I
think that you're you're rightfully
existentially saying like oh like could
I possibly be doing impacting a billion
people within three years with some
major project like yeah yeah we we also
you know you get it but at the same time
like I'm glad that you know that you are
you've not you've given me that like
that you get that that you do have
serious impact at the same time Thanks
yeah yeah it's hard I am my own worst
critic all the time you know like I will
always find a reason to belittle myself
and think that what I'm doing it's not
important but when I look objectively at
what I've done yeah
as you said I can never properly measure
what kind of impact I'm having I can
never even properly measure how many
people are actually seeing my stuff yeah
I have view counts on YouTube and listen
counselling Spotify but it goes far
beyond that like some people download it
on their phones and listen to it all the
time I can't legitimately count that and
I can't count how much they're spreading
it around to their friends or you know
whether it's maybe save someone's life I
don't really know you know I don't know
how big my reach is and it always
surprises me when I go out on tour and
find out that people who I've never even
met before have been watching my videos
every single day yep
yep every single day yes crazy and so
then this is why lineages are very
important so if someone that has been
impacted by your music can then write
into you and tell you about how what
they've achieved after they were
impacted by your music yeah that's why
lineages are so
Kru crucial the song that that's what
cursive creativity is about it's about
passing on that inspiration I was
inspired by someone I inspire other
people you know yep I want to ask you
about this this is on the way out I have
a couple questions that we like asking
but one of them is that I wonder
we spoke quite a bit about this
throughout especially at the very
beginning but that do you what do you
feel as though a curse pre-birth do you
feel like you came from somewhere into
playground earth with an intention of
sorts haha me personally or everyone you
you you personally I don't know if my
destiny was preset at birth I don't
think anyone says I think we are all we
have all neutrally just been a clump of
cells without a brain without electrical
impulses no one knows what actually is
consciousness no one knows what creates
consciousness in their brains and so
therefore no one really knows what that
consciousness is telling that kid to do
it just kind of appears at one point
while you're developing and then you get
born and so I don't think anyone's
future and destiny is predetermined by
right at birth but what I do think is
that my upbringing and my shared
environment was my family and my
non-shared environment with my family
experiences that I had in school
experiences that I had by myself on the
Internet
those have started to shape me from the
very beginning to the person I am today
and those have always been pointing me
in the direction of I want to be a
public figure and what kind of public
figure I don't know but my family does
have a musical gene I have several
musical cousins my grandma was very
musical I have
just kind of a musical sense of my
family and that was probably genetic my
education in music also helped me decide
that music was something that I was good
at and I wanted to do so eventually I've
always you know this desire for
attention and this is this desire desire
to impact other people plus I want to be
do something with music came together to
create this nice yeah okay that makes us
yeah yeah and then how about do you
think we are alone in the cosmos no of
course not it's impossible super
impossible do you think we're alone I'm
asking the questions okay I think
there's so much nuance but yeah keep
going what do you think I mean it's very
possible that we are living in a
simulation I don't know the
technicalities of it because I'm not an
astrophysicist but Neil deGrasse Tyson
said that we're living in a simulation
or it's very likely that we are and
we'll never be able to know and if Neil
deGrasse Tyson says it then it's very
possible what I do think is that there
are a lot of coincidences that have
brought all of us into this world that
I've made single celled organisms
somehow develop into multi-celled
organisms and somehow create a nuclei
around that holds in their DNA and
became multi-celled functional animals
with a nervous system in consciousness
there is so much coincidence that has
happened here and no knows really how it
works
I'm not religious and so I don't think
that it's because of like divine
creation or anything what I do think is
that that process could have happened in
so many other places in this universe
and this universe is too big for us to
even comprehend it's gigantic
it I've seen kind of a video showing us
as this like tiny earth and like
expanding out out into like the universe
the universe is ridiculously big do you
did you see
that photo of the black hole like that
is so far away and that is the size of
three billion suns do you know how much
a billion is it's a lot do you know how
big the Sun is it's really big this
universe cannot be measured there's so
many there's an infinite amount of
places and planets on which what
happened to us could have happened so I
don't think we're alone in the universe
I just think we're never gonna find out
who we're sharing it with and then you
said you thought we were also in a
simulation yeah the whole universe could
be a simulation like this gigantic
universe where we're never gonna find
out where the other living beings are
the other intelligent living beings are
could all just be part of a video game
I've had that feeling a lot of times
feeling like I was living in the matrix
there we go in in a video game yeah like
I was being controlled by someone else
or just ultimate control thing and
obviously that brings us in a question
of religion right as I said that I don't
believe in God I'm not religious but
simulation surely no yeah like that you
know did he set all this in motion did
he did did he create us did she did they
you know it's really hard to tell I
can't I don't believe in you know
religious God specifically but whether
there's something behind the simulation
if we can find out that it's a
simulation I don't think we'll ever know
unfortunately I really want to know but
I don't think we can in the last
question what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
oh man
I think the most beautiful thing in the
world is someone who is able to be
themselves 100% authentic
keeping it real yeah yeah that's a great
one
excellent excellent Lex Lex I've loved
this conversation I've had enough it's
such a good time
me too I'm so glad I did this I'm so
glad we did this
thank you this is really fun
yay I think it was one of the best
interviews I've ever done actually I was
I was you know I was chill
I was composed and you were asking some
great questions so thank you for the
conversation very much appreciate it
we're really happy you were able to
shine so brightly on the program and we
have the excellent technical direction
of Ron Vargas that has you do shine Lex
I think you're a badass I think you're
very talented you're very smart and you
just keep on doing what you're doing
thank you Ron yeah thank you yeah we
need the nerd culture explosion you're
right there you know you're right there
so I love it
huge shout out to Round of August thank
you for producing and directing you
shout out to all of those that have been
watching or listening we greatly greatly
appreciate you tuning into the episode
we would love for you to check out some
of the links below to the lexicon
artists com also Lex's band camp link
Facebook Instagram patreon YouTube
Twitter go check those out give the
support give the support become a patron
you know how to do it also give us your
thoughts in the comments below on the
future of rap and nerd culture in
general go and spread that out to your
family your friends your co-workers
people online on social media get
talking about the future of nerd culture
we need it to solve the biggest
challenges ahead of us and also support
the organizations the entrepreneurs the
artists around the world that you
believe in support simulation our links
are below support the local ones in your
communities as well and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]